All right, let's get to hatred. Male, it is
that time of the week. Hatred mail. When a
professional voiceover artist does interpretive
readings of the hatred mail that I get a quick
reminder about Patriot mail first
because we don't care about liberal Cox so
much that we spend our time writing to them.
Patriot may be written by patriots who hate
David Pacman because America and because freedom.
So I, I think that this week's hatred, male,
I think it's racist, right? I mean, let's
take a look at it
just came across this channel. Your channel
is nothing but liberal propaganda, appealing
to uneducated fucking idiots. I'm sure anyone
who has Trump derangement syndrome and can't
deal with the real world loves this channel.
If anyone wants a good laugh, stop by and
listen to this complete idiot and read the
comments. Be Your comedy. What happened
to old bone bongos? Red Line. So this entire,
oh, Bunga Oh, Bunga and Obama are those racist
terms about Barack Obama? My, my impression
is that they are, that they are sort of ridiculing
or, or referencing. Um, what, what are sort
of like stereotypical, uh, quote backwards
sounding African words or names or something
like that. Is [inaudible] Bumba maybe re like
related to bumbling like a bumbling fool.
I don't know. Uh, it doesn't sound great to
me though, but once again, um, uh, I, I think
that it's important to remember that even
when hatred iots engage with our content,
when hatreds show up on my youtube channel
and downvote my videos or leave a negative
comment, it's still engagement. It still helps
us on the youtube algorithm. When you hate
listen to my podcast, it's still good for
me. It's still a listen that I can then go
to an advertiser and say, this is the number
we have.
And if five or 10% of those are patriots,
then that's five or 10% more that we can charge
for advertising. Just remember that folks,
the best way to fight patriotism directly
is to become a member on my website. Join
pacman.com using the coupon code hatred, 40
h, a, T, R, I. O. T. Four zero. You save 40%
off of your membership and the hatred huts
burst into flames spontaneously because their
attempts to sabotage or sabotage the show.
To quote William Shatner, it's been awhile
since I said that a don't work. And that is
a really great thing for independent progressive
media.